well let's get into it let's get into it
so
you want to start with your favorite
game wait this is always the question we
decided do we start low and go high
do we start high and go low what are you
feeling what do you feel you want to
start with a game you hate the most or
love
the most best or worst me yeah
this is the thing because best game is
something that like you can talk about
for a long time
worst game is like everyone always asks
that what's your least favorite movie
what's your least favorite game like
i don't know i probably forgot it
because it was so
that's true indifference is truly the
opposite of love
yeah i do i do have some that are are
kind of obvious and some that i think
some people will not
agree with so we could we could burn the
bridge immediately
if you want to let's do that it's a
little cold in here let's start a fire
let's do it yeah
um i mean the obvious ones are stuff
like
like fallout 76 because that was just a
show
and you have stuff like the old e.t game
and superman
sure um classics that's true
that's like that's low-hanging fruit
solo i was going to say
that sonic 06 would have been one
have either of you ever played sonic
2006 no
that's not the 3d was it that bad no
it's
it's pretty bad oh uh why why because
it's just
it well it's not my least favorite game
now um
but it's it just it didn't work it was
like what have you done to sonic
it's like you took him outside gave him
a coffee enema and then shot him
and did you just like it yeah it was
glitchy you'd go through the walls the
gameplay just wasn't good the story was
crap
and it was my least favorite game for a
long time until i tweeted about it
and then the sonic team saw it
oh i love that wow love when that then
personally sent me a physical edition of
sonic the hedgehog jacksepticeye edition
oh my god they made you your own edition
yeah and i they put my fake quote on it
that said the world's greatest video
game of all
time i have one of the shittiest games
of all time with my name on it and it
even has like
pictures of me on the back oh they
trolled you so it's like
signed by the team wow wow
so funny so i'm like so you can't hate
it that much now no
can't do it this is how we get then now
we know bribery works on you we know we
know your price
yeah a little photoshop and a box cover
i'm cheap that's what it takes
if i ever hate you just